[Music]
hey guys
it's quinn please click the like button
so that the youtube algorithm recognizes
that i've uploaded
and circulates my video thanks guys
isaac asimov's foundation series
was the first ever science fiction
series to contain a full-fledged
galactic empire the entire series
involves the centuries-long plan
of a man known as harry selden to
restore the human galactic empire
after a great crash which led to a dark
age
harry seldon was able to predict the
fall of the first galactic empire
by the use of a form of mathematics
known as psycho history
which was able to predict human behavior
over time at mass
psycho history gail dornick using
non-mathematical concepts
has defined psycho history to be that
branch of mathematics which deals with
the reactions of human conglomerates
to fixed social and economic stimuli
essentially the empire fell due to the
capital planet trantor's inability
to adequately handle the bureaucratic
and administrative demands of such a
large empire
containing 25 million worlds harry
selden's solution would ultimately prove
to be extremely complicated
and multifaceted but it is presented
initially
as the creation of the foundation the
foundation would be founded on a distant
world
terminus and would have encyclopedist
whose job was to record all human
knowledge in the universe
inside the encyclopedia galactica
thousands of humans would devote
themselves to the project
in an effort to preserve the knowledge
of all mankind in the hope that doing so
could shorten the interregnum which
would follow the collapse of the empire
all my project my thirty thousand men
with their wives and children
are devoting themselves to the
preparation of an encyclopedia galactica
they will not complete it in their
lifetimes i will not even live to see it
fairly begun but by the time trantor
falls
it will be complete and copies will
exist in every major library in the
galaxy
though it had been initially stated that
the foundation existed solely to create
the encyclopedia galactica
is revealed a third of the way through
the first book fifty years after its
initial creation
that the encyclopedia is not the true
purpose of the foundation at
all harry selden had left a vault on
terminus
it was set to open on a specific date in
which the pre-recorded holograms of
selden would appear to address the
foundation
the vault opens and the hologram of him
reveals the truth
the encyclopedia foundation to begin
with
is a fraud and always has been it is a
fraud in the sense that neither i nor my
colleagues
care at all whether a single volume of
the encyclopedia is ever published
it has served its purpose since by it we
extracted an
imperial charter from the emperor by it
we attracted the hundred thousand humans
necessary for our scheme
and by it we managed to keep them
preoccupied while events shaped
themselves
until it was too late for any of them to
draw back
harry selden tells them that the path
for the foundation
is inevitable they will be faced with a
series of crises
that he himself had predicted through
psycho history
he tells them that in each crisis they
will be forced along a singular path
due to the circumstances set in place
the past they will take
will be passed laid out in harry selden
psycho history calculations
as i said psycho history could predict
human psychology at mass
over long distances of time as it
develops over the centuries
the foundation is met with crisis after
crisis
just as selden had predicted
each time his pre-recorded hologram
appears to advise them
later in the series however selden's
plan is shaken
with the arrival of the mule the mule
possessed powerful mentality powers
because of this he skewed the results of
seldon's predictions
because of the mule selden's attempt at
preserving humanity
was almost completely thwarted the saga
of the foundation continues for hundreds
of years
and involves the struggles faced by
humanity during the dark ages
and the rise of a new human galactic
empire
the main series in the foundation saga
is considered a trilogy
foundation foundation and empire and the
second foundation
but there are actually seven books in
total in the foundation series
not including asimov's galactic empire
series
or robot series two prequels prelude to
foundation
and four at the foundation and two
sequels foundation's edge
and foundation and earth asimov's
foundation is widely considered to be
one of the most influential science
fiction sagas of all time
many of the most successful science
fiction sagas ever like dune
star wars and others would not exist
without foundation
thank you guys for watching make sure
you like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas